was hast du vor das wollen wir einfach
raus
alles gut bei dir ja alles okay wohin
wohin fahren wir siehst du gleich
vertrau mir was hast du vor
lass dich überraschen ja ich bin doch
keine acht mehr sag doch was keine
Überraschung ich kenne deine
Überraschung hast du eigentlich
deine Regenjacke an ja habe ich
deine Mütze mein Handy 32% Akku was will
ich noch meine Heim oder
Meldebescheinigung dein
dann
mal kurz aussteigen was ist los alles
gut
ich hole Dich dann später ab okay ja was
ich hole Dich später vertrau mir
Weg viel Spaß
was soll ich hier Sally
ihr wisst ja wir stellen ja seit zwei
Jahren hier diese handgemachten
keramikflaschen hier in Isny care und
zwar sind die vom Design her richtig
schön wir haben ganz viele tolle
verschiedene Farben von Rainbow über
einfarbig über Pinselmalerei bis hin zu
diesen Streifen wirklich alle
wunderschön und die stellen wir auch
weiterhin natürlich her aber natürlich
haben wir uns gedacht wir möchten auch
was Neues erschaffen deswegen haben wir
uns jetzt eine neue Form überlegt eine
schöne Runde bauchige Form das ist
übrigens kein Regen das ist die Sonne
die auf dieses Dach kommt und dann sich
die aluminiumdächer quasi bisschen
zusammenziehen später wieder ausdehnen
deswegen hat sich das hier an wie so ein
schöner Sommerregen ist aber leider kein
schöner Sommerregen jedenfalls haben wir
hier eine schöne rundliche Flasche die
aber
hier richtig schön flach ist das heißt
wird ein richtig tolles elegantes Design
ich habe mir ganz ganz tolle Bemalungen
dazu überlegt aber ich würde sagen wir
stellen erstmal die Flaschen her Keramik
ist ja ein Steingut ein richtig
natürlicher Stoff und unser Ton kommt
hier regional aus der Türkei weil aber
der Ton ist er natürliches Material
dieses mal ein bisschen zu dunkel
geraten ist beziehen wir jetzt auch noch
und das finde ich ganz toll auch Ton aus
der Ukraine das heißt unterstützen hier
auch die Ukraine und haben auch von dort
Ton mischen den mit dem türkischen Ton
damit wir einfach einheitlich immer
unsere gleichbleibende Qualität haben
wir haben den Ton jetzt bereits
angemischt ich habe hier unsere Formen
das sind die moles also die Gießformen
und hier gieße ich jetzt unsere Keramik
rein
[Musik]
und dann gießt man hier immer wieder die
Flüssigkeit nach also den Ton nach weil
das ganze sich ja auch setzt und es
macht mir jetzt so lange bis es gerannt
voll ist und dann wird es gleich
ausgegossen alles was wir Ausgießen wird
dann wieder recycelt und quasi wieder
verwendet und einfach neu angemischt da
wird also nichts verschwendet was ich
richtig gut finde
[Musik]
die trocknen jetzt hier bis morgen aber
wir haben natürlich schon welche
vorbereitet gestern und können die jetzt
direkt aus der Form rauslassen
[Musik]
jetzt werden die keramikflaschen
rausgelöst das heißt ich kratze hier
oben
erstmal den Überschuss ab
kannst dann hinlegen Boden weg
wunderschön dann hier vorne den
Überschuss Weg jetzt ganz vorsichtig
sind unsere Fingerspitzen
en und damit später der Ausgießer drauf
passt und der Deckel und alles
einheitlich ist steche ich jetzt hier
noch die Öffnung aus
[Musik]
die keramikflaschen sind jetzt bereit
zum Trocknen nach dem Trocknen werden
sie auch schön hell die sehen jetzt
dunkler aus weil sie einfach noch die
Feuchtigkeit haben und daran erkennt man
auch immer ganz gut ob Sie schon
getrocknet sind die Mode ist fertig
jetzt müssen wir die natürlich noch ein
bisschen ausbessern hier die Naht
wegschleifen hier oben noch ein bisschen
ausbessern innenauspusten und dann gehen
wir direkt zum Ausgießen und bemalen
macht die Hunde weg
[Musik]
mach die Hunde weg was ist denn die
Macht die Universität beißen nicht doch
nein du hast ja abgerichtet nein
oh mein Gott nein doch komm komm
also wir sind hier in Denizli und zwar
mit dem Levin zusammen und mit dem Günni
der lebend geht wirklich überall in alle
Provinzen der Türkei und der weiß ganz
genau wo er seine Trüffel findet weil
jedes Mal wenn er irgendwo drüber findet
markiert er diese stellen oder weiß ganz
genau im nächsten Jahr sind wir wieder
Trüffel Trüffel sind was ganz ganz
besonderes das sind Edelpilze und zwar
sind die im Boden in der Nähe von Bäumen
und zwar ziehen sie ganze Energie aus
diesen Bäumen heraus oder benutzen diese
Energie und hier gibt es gibt einen
schwarzen Trüffel und weißen Trüffel wir
suchen hier vorrangig den schwarzen
Trüffel und alles richtig cool für Pasta
für Nudeln für für Pizza und für rotes
Fleisch ja auf jeden Fall lebend und wir
wir gehen jetzt los auf die trüffeljagd
Günni hat seine Waffe dabei weil es ist
könnt auch gefährlich werden wir sind
hier zum Eichenwald und es könnten
irgendwelche Beeren kommen oder Wölfe
und da wird eine beschützen er ist auch
ein bisschen angezogen als würde in den
Krieg ziehen kann es sein du siehst aus
als also du kommst aus dem Kriegsgebiet
ja
aber ich habe noch nicht gesagt dass du
lass es mir ein Unfall aussehen gell ah
okay alles klar also jetzt geht's los
herzlich gemerkt stecken die Trüffel bei
Dir rein Beutel rein ne
[Musik]
woher hast du wahrscheinlich die Trüffel
nicht mehr die zwei verstehen uns ja eh
nichts wo sind die zwei Trüffeln
ich glaube mir die ich glaube die haben
vergessen dass wir die Trüffel haben
okay
[Musik]
ich gönni aus alman suche kleine Murat
mit große Bauch aus Türkei du sehen
Murat Türkei
kleine kleine Murat türkmann
[Applaus]
hallo ich große deutsche Mann sucht
kleine türkische Mann mit Bauch
ich gönne aus Deutschland große Mann
sucht türkische Mann kleine mit so Bauch
hast du gesehen ja da ist dort hinten du
sprichst ja Deutsch ja natürlich spreche
ich Deutsch ihr seid ja einer dümmer als
der andere wieso denn das ich weiß nicht
ihr macht halt Blödsinn wo ist er der
dort hinten ja danke danke tschüss
der kleine Türke mit der Kappe ja der
spricht perfekt deutschke verarscht mich
doch wird alles verstanden alles
verstanden alles was wir ihm gesagt
haben alles was du über ihn gesagt hast
[Musik]
das ist jetzt das Frühstück jetzt gerade
hier an den Olivenhain wie gesagt mit
Eiern das nennt sich die war nicht so
ein Grieß ja so Grießkuchen ist es und
es ist so
gerade gemacht haben wie gesagt mit
Spinat und Käse
ich habe eine
Überraschung warte
[Musik]
forever
blue das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich das
beste Spieler was du jemals gegessen
hast frische Eier und frischen schwarzen
Trüffel und das Besondere Trüffel ist
der die die Aromen die entfalten sich am
besten mit Fett dabei ist also eine
Sahne oder Fett und die Wärme Wärme ich
ganz ganz wichtig so 30 40 Grad und hast
eine richtige dieses richtige Aroma und
wenn fetten guter Geschmacksträger ist
dann können wir noch bestimmt einen
Hammer Trüffelöl draus machen oder so
ein richtig geniales wo hast du nur
immer diese Ideen her unglaublich oder
du bist ja wie ein Stein ja nur kleiner
gell ja oder oder
wie Zahnstein bin ich vielleicht ja ja
[Musik]
während unser Olivenöl momentan gerade
in der Filtration ist kümmern wir uns um
diese Trüffel die wir gestern gesammelt
haben wir haben hier ungefähr ein
bisschen mehr als ein Kilo vom Preis
habe ich sagen 1.500 Euro an Trüffeln ja
Wahnsinn jetzt mal ganz ehrlich willst
du das persönlich sowas kaufen willst du
1000 € für Trüffel ausgeben mit 100
Jahren nicht ich auch nicht muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen deswegen machen wir
ein cooles Öl draus werden dann auch in
den Shop reinmachen ich weiß noch nicht
wann es erhältlich ist wir probieren es
einfach mal aus aber ich garantiert euch
wir geben nicht alles das ist ein ganz
ganz tolles Trüffelöl das ist auch jede
leisten kann okay
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Flaschen hier werden jetzt am Rand
schön gesäubert also abgeschliffen
danach ausgepustet und kleine Löcher die
hier vielleicht entstanden sind durch
Luft werden dann einfach wieder
aufgefüllt und fertig dann sind Sie
bereit und bemalt zu werden
ich denke jetzt wahrscheinlich Ort die
Arme die sitzt dort den ganzen Tag in
der Wärme und macht das hier und staubt
ein und alles aber ich muss euch echt
sagen dass für mich so richtig meditativ
ich hätte das gerne ich würde gerne als
Workshop machen in Deutschland
meditationsflaschen machen so nenne ich
den Kurs ihr habt nur Flaschen um euch
herum und möchte deine Auszeit dann
macht eigene Flaschen das ist der
Werbespot dazu
[Musik]
hey ihr Mäuse wisst ihr was jetzt kommt
der lustigste Party jetzt gehen wir zum
Bemalen und wir gehen jetzt ins
Malatelier und dort können wir uns
Designs überlegen für unsere schönen
Flaschen
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir hier im Atelier und ihr
seht auch schon seit dem letzten Mal hat
sich vieles getan den letzten hatten wir
so ein ganz ganz kleines Atelier
mittlerweile kann der hassanos da hier
viele mehr Menschen beschäftigen viel
mehr Frauen und Männer die für ihn
arbeiten weil es eben unsere Produktion
machen und er hat ein richtig großes
Lager das ist echt schön das zu sehen
[Musik]
ich bin ich bin richtig verzweifelt
Mädels ich habe ein richtiges Problem
jetzt
ja weil ich schon Designs hatte Rainbow
Streifen das Auge und jetzt kommt ihr
mir hier mit Ideen und eigenen
Kreationen okay ihr seid einfach so
krasser Designer dass ich jetzt nicht
mehr weiß was ich machen soll Ella und
Samira jetzt muss ich der Werkstatt hier
erklären was ihr eure Designs auch
machen sollen
Kuni was machst du 455 die ist abgefüllt
von Günni hört ich abgepfiffen
leute guckt nach Günni abgefüllte
Flaschen da ist immer ein bisschen mehr
drin
von mir ausgeliefert haben ja so jetzt
haben wir ja die die handgemachten
Flaschen von der Sally bekommen aus
isnik und während ich die Kartons Falte
Wert wird wird
inzwischen gerne Türkei der heißt nicht
mehr in der Zwischenzeit wieder die
Flaschen abfüllen
[Musik]
so sieht's aus richtig cool die ganzen
Farben richtig toll gemacht und jetzt
geht es eigentlich zu Sally gerade mit
unserem Trüffelöl mit allen Ölen wo wir
hier haben wird eine ganz ganz tolle
Geschichte das haben wir gut hingekriegt
wenn ihr da komm her ja
dabei ist das immer gesehen hat was für
eine harte Arbeit ist es muss ganz
ehrlich zugeben also ist nicht nur weil
die Kamera da ist sondern wirklich ich
ist Wert ja definitiv ich bin voll
wichtig dass es so ist wirklich
so schön die Milben ausgetauscht und ab
geht's zur Sally wir nehmen das ist
meins das ist meins ja wir sehen uns
tschüss
ich will jetzt ziemlich aufgeregt weil
jetzt heute dieses Video online geht und
wir vor einigen Wochen in der Türkei
waren und es war für uns wie das so ein
schöner Ausflug ein richtig emotionaler
Ausflug ich lief es einfach die Menschen
dort zu unterstützen zu sehen wir hat
sie arbeiten und was für tolle Arbeit
sie eben verrichten und für mich ist
jetzt auch Premiere denn ich sehe heute
auch die olivenölflaschen das erste Mal
komplett fertig verpackt und wir haben
uns ja für diese Flasche entschieden
weil es einfach mal eine richtig schöne
neue Form ist eine Flasche in der man
das Olivenöl hat die Flasche später als
Vase verwenden kann oder eben doch
wieder auffüllen kann mit frischem
Olivenöl was man in diesem Video auch
ganz gut wieder sehen kann ist dass ja
hinter der ganzen Olivenöl Produktion
bei uns einfach keine Maschine riecht
steckt das sind Menschen die da wirklich
Handarbeit leisten und jeder einzelne
Flasche ist auch wirklich ein
handgemachtes Unikat deswegen ist es
auch so dass vielleicht mal der eine
Pinselstrich etwas dicker ist der andere
etwas dünner die Farbe etwas abweichen
kann oder auch zum Beispiel wie hier
einfach mal so kleine ist sind ja keine
Fehler es sind einfach kleine Macken die
jede Flasche so mit sich bringt und ich
bin einfach dafür dass man Ressourcen
nicht verschwendet und wir schauen und
prüfen jede Flasche durch und es ist
wirklich alles so mit bestem Wissen und
Gewissen hergestellt aber jede Flasche
ist ein Unikat genauso wie jeder Mensch
auf dieser Welt und deswegen darf auch
jede Flasche etwas anders aussehen das
sollte man finde ich immer wissen und
ich habe hier zu Hause bei mir natürlich
auch meine Samira und Ella Flaschen die
wir ursprünglich verlosen wollten aber
ich muss sagen meine Mama Herz lässt es
echt nicht so ich werde diese Flaschen
zu Hause bei mir behalten und einfach
immer schön dran denken was das für ein
toller Ausflug in der Türkei war und wir
kreativ meine zwei Mädels einfach sind
deswegen behalten wir die hier in Ehren
und ich werde euch aber vier Flaschen
signieren gleich im Anschluss
handsignierte Flaschen und die dürft ihr
dann gerne gewinnen und ihr schreibt mir
einfach später unter dieses Video am
besten wenn ihr die Flasche gewinnen
möchtet was euch in diesem Video am
besten gefallen hat war es ein Moment in
der Türkei war es auf dem olivenfeld
oder war es vielleicht die Tatsache dass
ich Murat im Wald ausgesetzt habe kann
natürlich auch sein denn auch Murat und
Günne das war so ein Abenteuer für sich
muss ich sagen und ob die zwei mit ihrer
Mission Trüffelöl durchkommen oder nicht
das steht jetzt noch in den Sternen denn
die zwei tüfteln gerade immer noch an
ihre Rezeptur aber lustig war es auf
jeden Fall und natürlich habe ich beide
wieder mit nach Hause genommen ist ja
klar und was mir auch ganz ganz neu
haben und diese Flasche die haben wir
entwickelt als wir in der Türkei waren
ich hatte nämlich auch Karo aus meinem
Team mit dabei caro ist eine ganz ganz
junge dynamische Frau die bei mir im
Team mitarbeitet und einfach mega
kreativ und ganz ganz toll ist und wir
saßen da ich weiß noch ganz genau die
Katze war da wir haben gerade die Katze
gestreichelt und haben uns die Flaschen
angeschaut und ich habe gesagt Caro ich
hätte einfach gerne eine Flasche die
einen Olivenbaum beinhaltet und das so
keine normale Flasche sein
deswegen haben wir uns auch für diese
Flasche entschieden wir hatten
verschiedene Muster verschiedene Designs
und Caro hat sofort drauflos gezeichnet
und ist eine Flasche die wir dann auch
frisch gegossen haben weil sie eben
nicht eben ist sondern einfach diese
erhabung hier hat und diese dieser Baum
der da drauf ist einfach wunderschön
gestaltet ist und die Farbe finde ich
wundervoll und das ist einfach so ein
Stück Weg Natur was man sich eben mit
nach Hause nimmt und eben eine
wunderschöne Flasche zu Hause hat und
ich freue mich dass Sie auch jetzt
wieder mit dabei wart auf unserer Reise
in die Türkei das hier ist tatsächlich
erst teil 1 denn wir waren wirklich eine
lange Zeit in der Türkei und jetzt folgt
in wenigen Wochen schon Teil 2 und 3 und
noch ein weiterer Teil und ich freue
mich da auch schon sehr drauf und vor
allem bin ich muss ich sagen ganz ganz
stolz auf mein ganzes Team die hier
hinter der Kamera im Schnitt in der
Grafik bei der Fotografie und überall
arbeiten weil jeder und jede einzelne
bei mir im Team einfach grandiose Arbeit
richtet es ist einfach schön mit euch zu
arbeiten ich bin sehr glücklich dass wir
das Video heute online gestellt haben
vielen vielen Dank für eure Zeit schön
dass ihr auch beim Live-Chat mit dabei
wart der Live Chat ist für mich immer
was ganz Besonderes weil ich dann immer
eure live Reaktionen sehe und ich bin da
immer gerne beim Chat mit dabei und
unterhalte mich mit Euch vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen freu dich auf die
nächsten Teile und macht wie gesagt
gerne beim Gewinnspiel mit und schreibt
mir was Ihr an diesem Video am schönsten
fandet ich glaube das motiviert mein
Team auch noch mal mehr und mich
natürlich auch und ich freue mich sehr
darüber also schönen Abend noch und bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss
ich kann mich von den Flaschen nicht
trennen bis da dieser Mira und die Ella
[Musik]
das könnte ich nicht die bleiben bei mir
die haben das so schön gemacht und ich
glaube die nächsten Flaschen die darf
einfach Samira designen und Ella die
zwei die sind die sind einfach der
Hammer
da platzt mir Mama herzvorstand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in
Duisburg
[Musik]